hello Ricky welcome to the show and
welcome to the show get in mind when
celebrating Jim Norton's birthday Oh is
that big no is nobody did we first saw
it it was it was it was a pound cake
baked by the mother of one of our new
employees well I don't know pound kaijus
it's not that yeah yeah yeah it's not a
bird that one yeah
yes happy birthday thank you for holding
49 49 excellent good work yeah I mean we
wouldn't thought it usually is that long
believe me I certainly didn't know I
know not with my practices if life was
fair I would've been dead in 1992 when
you know the whole thing broke after
this believe I got away with a lot of
naughty behavior oh right in when did
you wipe that sweat off your brow was it
like just as it was at the tail end of
the 90s weeks ago when I took the I took
an oral HIV test you can do that with
saliva yeah because I'm so special
fighting now to get an HIV test and I
came up negative we talked about in the
show but it was [ __ ] horrifying I got
that same thing every time you do write
be two weeks after get tested for the
NDA yeah well Benson it means I stopped
doing movies because you're getting it's
getting too scary and what coming out
positive and you have to get to sit
every two weeks so can you imagine going
to strong blood every second two weeks
sir
well Ricky your relationships you'd have
to wear but that's gotta be nice yeah
now I don't even like having a blood
test for house once a year I just scream
when the need of it I got oh my god it's
horrible it's just like an invasion
I started pho because I feel like I'm
gonna vomit as well so yeah I could
never do her with the pain of the water
it is it's a pain of the loss of blood
it's phobic it's just purely it's wrong
you shouldn't have a needle in your arm
I mean I feel like I come out in a sweat
and I've gone on being a baby like oh
sorry and then I can feel it scratching
and I just want to vomit I just can't
stand it it's just it's horrible the
smell of running alcohol the cut the
cold no yeah the alcohol I will you know
in the end
and then when it's over it's just over
and I don't care it's like crying it's
like what that's ridiculous but I'm
sweating now thinking about going
because right after it's like it didn't
hurt yeah why do a video you can over
say yeah another time sometimes like
they missed the vein and like when we
get some time to be in it's like tight
and it's cold days are warm day
something you bled that alone you have
to sit there and you're like then like
I'm like like a heroin addict they shoot
in between their toes yeah shoot in the
vein behind their balls they shot
because so it doesn't show but yeah as
worn out there it's but yeah it'll [ __ ]
up there be no veins left and also like
you don't want to constantly get in
trouble like if you have an office job
and you're shooting heroin you don't
fight I want to do in your arms you'd
probably do it behind the leg or in
between the toes I didn't I think people
that don't have to regularly take AIDS
test don't realize like how good they
have it I've never thought to myself
like oh this is great I don't take any
AIDS test
well I mean you're just sitting there
going like you have no idea how lucky
you are that you don't have to do with
it taking this swab because it's an
automatic saying I couldn't do the blood
thing again I had to just do an
automatic swab to see if I had it and it
was one of the worst 30 minutes my life
well I just because the affair the
result not not because the actual thing
oh yeah there was nothing you swab it
anybody works big with your mouth oh
certain better things I think one man's
worse is another man $350 totalizing all
perspective
well yeah high with sexual activity well
not really of course you know man
hydrants would you say low risk no I
certainly wouldn't say no no I certainly
wouldn't discover in the middle
yeah but I'm okay yeah it's good to know
you said it but it's scary
yes really scenario you're in a
relationship you're lucky you don't have
to do that you're not worried about that
no I've never done that all that would
be that would be pretty frightening with
the results but it's less frightening
these days isn't it HIV it's just it's
like it's done isn't it it's like let's
make a oh Lord nowadays you take a pill
you're fine well it happened me I'm not
thank you you lose some weight
yeah you don't have to worry about it
anymore are you getting like wonderful
benefits to be honest a key to get you
an apartment you can say what it is
you're mad yeah where do you where the
apartment located um it depends where
they put you but I have fun
you're thinking of Jamie yes I sigh
another real estate yeah yeah I'm not in
Columbus Circle I think that I mean it
you're gonna cheap apartment you get a
psychologist you get your medication
when you get everything taken care of
yeah that's I guess let's look on the
brighter side yeah why have they do this
really why do it my way I recommend
decline don't sign this at home right
yeah say a trap will prevent you from
getting yeah and then if I'm have HIV
there's something you can take which
will prevent you from passing it and
keep your viral load undetectable
because now you can control your viral
load so when you do even go get tested
does your positive but it doesn't come
out pond yes not yeah yeah I'd rather be
a releves and kids wow I thought that go
down with Churchill that's amazing that
one guy one day you have a cold 25 years
who said I'd rather AIDS and kids I'd
rather have AIDS in kids well they are
most kids say my children my age my I
don't look back no I never great I love
my AIDS yeah and they go to college who
I'd rather have AIDS in kids we like
that we show you I am and I wanted to
see you live at the the theater of the
garden you do act is really funny man I
haven't given you live in years but it
was legitimately funny I laugh it's the
last time the first time I watch a
comedy show in a long time and it was so
good I don't think I'm really really
great take on everything I don't want to
give away any years but I keep think
about your [ __ ] helicopters I thought
about that a hundred times it says all
right you know right yeah it's sort of
like there's a structure to it when all
the jokes have dropped in as opposed to
I think my first sort of for stand-up
swear I thought of funny things and I
tried to put them all together and this
one I sort of walked out and just spoke
for an hour about a subject and found
the jokes after do not I mean yes so
it's much more of a structure to it it's
much more of an attitude to it and
there's much more of a it's more
cohesive than my first ball I think so
if it was like a story so I think you
can get away with more
is that the tougher is a writer though
because then if you come up with a joke
that you just like the joke if you can't
fit it into the narrative structure that
you're building you might not be able to
use well I didn't I didn't know that
that that's harder for the first four
because the first four sort of wrote it
as a writer and then went out and acted
it out oh I see what you say but this
one was easy because I just ran out and
told the truth right I just went out and
told the truth for an hour and and if
you've got if you've got the truth you
can't go wrong
yes and then jokes come to it and I can
digress and go but I'd come back to it
and so it's like I'm holding them it's
harder to hold them with the story than
the thousand fantastic jokes
you could go out you could watch some
one to a thousand jokes and you're
looking at your watch after twenty
minutes however good the jokes are
someone's telling you a story
you can't leave so right if you can if
you can build a narrative into a comedy
you've already won because they don't go
away thinking I didn't last much they go
around thinking I thought was the best
hour and half of my do not I mean yes
because they liked it while you're there
you're like alright not only are you
entertained but you're waiting to see
where it goes you know if you're going
somewhere I think that what you're a
city between watching The Godfather and
your favorite sketches yeah you know you
turn off the sketch engine wait there's
not any important thing you can turn off
for sketches yeah the guy finally just a
bunch of sketches put together it
actually just worked out nicely right
yeah we got a week I'm a story here yeah
yeah it started with a horse head same
like we got to build a federal Arizona
waters is MADtv that's if you're a good
storyteller I'm not a good storyteller I
don't know stories I think you are a
joke is the stories it's a short story I
guess I think sometimes you're you're
shy you're shy okay take them and you've
got you've got a story and you sort of
you try and cut it short because you
think this is an appropriate or this
isn't the forum but when you're doing
stand-up it is the forum because they've
come to see whatever you've got to say
so anything you do is the forum and you
know I mean yeah you couldn't drop you
couldn't drop any of your stories into
polite society now you can live because
they're there to see a disgusting 49
year old pervert do you not I mean
I pie wouldn'ta phrase it like that
while I can't see you for slander either
fairly valid point
yeah I guess when they show up to see it
but the thing I liked I think Sam liked
it too is it was the jokes were really
great but it was a lot of it was not
when people hit a certain level of fame
and celebrity like you know you're on
that top level but you don't you don't
soften it it's as harsh as I want it to
be from a comedian but that's really
interesting to say that because that was
a concern right now I started going out
being ironic about being rich and famous
right and when you're you know it's all
about status with it you know as a young
comedian you can show off you can say
things that you can't say you can slag
people off that you can't do because as
your status Rises you've got a great
responsibility
it's you know so now I suppose compared
to the audience they know they know I'm
wealthy they know I have some power so
I've got to try and get back that low
status when I do it by inviting them in
to private jets and meeting the Queen I
invite them in I'm the outsider I broke
in and I'm telling them as my friends so
phony it is so I get my status I get my
low estate it's by being on their side
against the man they know deep down I'm
in I'm in with that growl sure like the
Golden Globes I purposely went out with
a beer and then called and pulpy vintage
a pill-popping disgusting deviance
because I'm I'm representing the guys at
home who aren't winning awards and I
want billionaires do you see what I'm
saying yes yeah that's the only what
you've got you've got you have got or
you play with it and I say things like
people say I'm out of touch because I'm
rich I am I could have this place burnt
down process you know and I say people
now you can you do normal a comedy how
can you relate to ordinary scum you know
and they know what I'm doing yeah I know
because I'm being ironic they know he
isn't like that and it's a conscious
effort that I go out and a t-shirt and
jeans and drink a beer out of a can it's
all it's all to let them know that I
don't think I don't think I'm important
yeah it's really a comedian as soon
telling harsh one-liners it's sort of
you don't know what to make of them do
you not I mean
yeah I mean you got it wherever feels
for the person some guys have no money
and they can wear a jacket and be
comfortable some guys come from like
they started at open mics wearing a
blazer and that's who they are sure but
if we exactly gotta play with who you
are I think that's important as well
yeah yeah I think I think stand up a
part for the material and the honesty
and all about sitcom and stuff that is
about character but stand up is about
attitude I think they want to see what
you where you're coming from and once
they know who you are everything makes
sense that's what you can't go out of
character too much
I can't suddenly I can't suddenly start
doing puns because they're going what
where's wicket amazing what would be
right now yeah I I've dropped real jokes
because they're so real or fake and I
think my real stories are fake yeah just
let definitely - okay I'm Celeste all
the time there I write some real jokes
and they I always lose them because they
they put I take my eye off the ball so
because I'm telling real stories and
real anecdotes and stuff I had to Joe
come my friend committed suicide
recently he went upstairs and he went
through and just swallowed everything in
the bathroom cabinet he choked on a
tampon bye
but now they go oh yeah he's lying or
maybe he's lying about the stuff he
talked about his brother and his Matt so
I drop it cuz it's just not me summer
doesn't ring true you don't want to
compromise you yeah yeah because I don't
think the other stuff that is true isn't
true so funny you get once in a while
you get criticized for your stand-up but
by people who just don't like and I'm
like as a comedian I watch you I'm like
I'm critical of comedians and I watched
your act it was funny
like it wasn't a [ __ ] act it was a
funny stand-up act and I'm like why
would anybody see that unless they had a
problem with you for other reasons and
not enjoy that that's one thing that's
one thing funny you don't get complaints
to the people who've paid you get
complaints when they tell a joke on
Twitter and someone else says that's
disgusting what do you mean that you
didn't hear the joke you weren't there
if this reported you don't know you
don't know the context that context is
absolutely everything any one of my
lines taken out of context would look
horrific in context everyone knows what
I'm doing
just like they provoke rather evades
than children contact that sounds quite
a weird thing to say I'm hoping yes both
is room yes somehow made perfect on
success it hurt more when it comes does
it hurt at all when it comes from a
comedian all the decision were no I
don't know that it has I don't know that
a comedians ever criticized me for a
joke I've done it's out there that's a
new thing comics we attack and colonize
our yeah I don't like it happening than
to you no not to me so much but between
people there's like feuds whether I
think this is bringing us all down
yeah it's odd that you should know
you're allowed to not like someone and
you're allowed to you know but it is odd
it's a new way of that's how they get
noticed they're outraged well that's
because I never funny no I know I know
no I know I've got I've got one troll
that's a comic that just trying to get
my attention is right five years and I'm
just ignoring it and just ignore it
because I make him more famous exactly
you know you give the power by giving
him a ten but I wonder what the problem
with you only because like whether
there's guys that don't contribute
anything or not but like you use the
office I mean like and stuff since like
it's such an amazing contribution
comedic Lee and it kind of changed the
way a lot of TV was done and it made
everybody follow suit and then you
follow it up with extras like how can
anybody give you [ __ ] well because don't
because you can't be that guy 24/7 so
they say the real you and they don't
like the real you
I mean some people hate me for different
reasons some people hate me because I
exist and I don't believe in God there's
nothing I can do about that that's true
you know there are also I mean there are
also stand-ups who not successful
stand-ups but there are stand-ups who
kind of stopped at a certain level and
they will not accept anybody having
success that did not come up through the
club's telling jokes exactly the way I'm
not to defend mechanism that's ten right
I even fight they're saying that they're
suddenly saying we you're not a real
stand-up we are not still playing the
shitty clubs that I do right as a but
you know is this the story because I
could be as successful as you but I'm a
real well is there some people to say oh
I wouldn't have taken an advert that's
cuz you went off with it right you had
an option
give him Woody Allen stand up when he
said he got a phone call my bite oh my
god cooker yeah yeah we fight mr. Allen
we'd like you to do it I don't care what
his personal life [ __ ] could write a
joke ya know he's the best
- was it was the best yeah somebody now
Brad and Canada's saying s Ricki about
his shows in Toronto why would they were
my favorite though great they were you
know it seems it seems to have got
better as I go along and it should get
better you you you you know your match
for everything you do you play more but
there were some about the Canadian
crowds they were they were simmering
they were laughing between the jokes and
I played more I did I did I came out of
the same set exactly same set that I
thought there was ten minutes longer
just because it was a pleasure to be in
their company I just talked a little bit
more by the way I promote your gigs the
humanity tour it's legitimately a funny
funny hour or hour and a half whatever
it was I remember yeah
October 25th the theater at Madison
Square Garden which was where Sam and I
saw him the 28th Dolby Theatre in LA is
sold out the 30th still has a few
tickets available November 1st there's
all be in LA is a few tickets available
but go to one of those three shows if
you can and I'm not saying just cuz I
like you but it's doing really a great
thing settlement is I'm loving it more
than ever as well I just I think for
lots of reasons I think I'm I'm better
now I think I'm not just better but I
think I'm good for the first time I look
back at my first four and I think I
wasn't a real stand-up do not I mean
it's odd I think oh yeah I would I was
like an actor
telling lines yes I've written the jokes
but now I feel like a real stand-up also
I think it's good that it's a seven year
layoff because the world's changed sure
I think the world has changed more in
the seven years than any other seven
years in my lifetime right yeah as the
feet are feeling so it's great it was
about humanity anyway and all the other
worlds crumbling so that was funny great
tour name by the way and the tour
artwork is amazing I'm trying to name my
tour right now and I don't know what -
older and wiser I decided that's not I
mean
notes there get that again they get
these they get this multi irony of you
being older and wiser thing is yeah you
bet I can't believe I've lived this long
Jim Nord should have been dead in 88 -
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't know what to
call but that's such a great humanity is
such a great name and when it started
with the pomposity of comedians thinking
they can do a definitive study I like
this too that I do you know like animals
politics science and it was like
slightly ironic and I go off but
actually funnily enough this show is
about humanity it's the first one that
you could be it makes sense people feel
that I have seen a show about the world
and you know and it's more personal so I
talk about bringing that things have
changed and the other thing is I think
people know me after 15 years so I can
get away with more so I don't have to
Laden that the irony they they get what
I'm doing I they know you they know you
is Ricky Gervais stay don't know you as
a character from a show is because
exactly well does the other stand-up
stuff like they know you as you yeah
they don't need to guess they know
they're sort of getting the real me as
close to the real me as you can and
right exactly yeah so that's all those
reasons is certainly my favorite yeah
it's hard it's harder when they only
know you from one thing and then you're
trying to do this this new prize that
they don't even know who the real you is
like if they get to know you as a
comedian or from these things a lot
easier because I kind of know that
but that's still a danger when I play
like arenas and they set out quick and
the phone says we can do another one and
we can do another one it's dangerous
because that last one you do you have
prized money at the natives you do get
the floating voters you do get people
who who didn't have to rush to get a
ticket
they were huge fan when their friends
went long or they said oh I saw him in
Knight the museum or it was in the
Muppets and they go along and say why is
he talking about cancer and famine yeah
yeah I try and make sure that I know I
do the last so I put on say I was the
one that still sold out fast hmm so I
don't I don't hang around you know
because the I did three nights and they
still sell out fast and it every night
was great you do a fourth night in that
city you might see a few phones go on
all right
yes I that's how I am of course oh yeah
right you know they they didn't kill to
get a ticket yeah they they Oh stilted
it available oh yeah I quite liked him
in MSU do you know I know as much as you
feel you want to pick up more people I
don't know I just coming out you want to
help make do you need to be alright it's
like I'm here so yeah I want I want to
do that where I start adding shows and
stuff so I'm doing now eight seat venues
there's many venues to believe you can
sell out there Adam already saw half the
room that's the other thing I've really
I do what I do an arena I do like an
arena and there's an echo and I hate it
it's the word s I hate that comedy it's
not comedy and I still do them I don't
particularly in Europe when I'm only I
fly over for one day so I'm I did them
Sweden eleven thousand I'm doing
Copenhagen thirteen thousand and I'm and
it's too big you're throwing jokes into
nothing well also I can't play because
you can't you can't ad-lib when you're
waiting for the array right yeah it's
fake it's like shouting it's like
clearing your throat and shouting ouch
when you hit your hand with a hammer
yes not it's not real so if I can get a
Victorian theatre it's perfect I think
three or four thousand is just
absolutely perfect you get the wolf just
like you go all that's even louder in
arena
it just takes long exactly and it's like
I know so and you know it's there's
something there's something fantastic
and it it's honestly it's good for the
soul to do you know smaller venues
better for everyone I think yes that
some in some towns I can't do 15 shows
in a I'm not there long enough no I have
to go okay rarely do that and get
everyone who wants to see me to come
along I still wanna get thing we're
trying to find data that's Soho Theatre
is like booked out for a year and I know
that that's that's right Marv as very
smart it's very media and my favorite is
a Leicester Square Theatre it's 400 and
it's underground and it's Victorian and
lovely and sweaty and everyone I know
does their warm-ups there I love that
that is that is my favorite small venue
in London I'll do any of them I'm trying
to shoot over there before the end of
the year it's really but we've been
trying there like the avails but what
sometimes available is some they do
matinees they do sadly a Sundays at 4
o'clock and I was worried about that but
it's great they really comedy fans it's
such it's got a great yeah but let's
discuss it I'd really recommend it and
they're in the know it's almost
exclusively comedians it's not like you
have to got gone between schools
tap-dancing it's not luck of it it's
like a comedy theater it became its
niche so the the mailing list is so
smart they're comedy fans maybe I'll do
that I'll bring my fiancee Anna Tosh
with me it'll be nice square fear yeah I
really do want to get over there I just
I've been trying to get out of London as
well if you can where's-where's
Leicester Square that London nowadays
yes yeah but if you if you can do if you
can do a Manchester and you know a
Bristol live our liver pool but there
what about Birmingham
Birmingham's big burning games like a is
like a London really what's the black
sabbath's from so we do Birmingham just
said of us yet yes but I mark for their
thank you very much either despair well
isn't that kind of like a lower money
area or not blue-collar nothing I'm just
well everywhere is lower than London in
New York is it Tokyo London New York
everything's like but yeah yeah um and
what do you mean by that you mean that
you can't charge as much oh no I was I
was literally not not even thinking of
the child just like just I'm thinking
like Sabbath said they came from nothing
Ozzie had no shoes yeah but this far
you're just thinking about Sabbath
that's Colin yeah but there's five
Buddha people in Birmingham so even as a
percentage of poor people and
millionaires
there's only for that matter to me yeah
yeah yeah always for Birmingham people
that I care about I just started going
off on an Aussie yeah I really assure
you just think god I see you did and you
did by the way a very funny Graham
Norton with Sharon and Ozzy oh sorry I
think oh it was great
it just just just watching him just
watching him think is funny
did you a better talk show host and
Graham Norton that guy anybody Malcolm
now he's the best now because I was just
talking to Craig Ferguson right there's
no there's no chat shows anymore I don't
know why they call them chat shows
because there's not everything's like
ironic game plane to get a two-minute
clip on YouTube this until having a
conversation that's why podcast
yes because people want an hour
listening to someone what they've got to
say an interesting chat and now you go
on to show your clip and then play
underwater table tennis nauseating yeah
I don't know and I'd still do it but
it's like it's not a chat show I don't
know who's watching those shows up here
no one is no one's watching them at the
time there were my real questions like
it's it's so worth it with Treadwell
they won't even nobody's even going to
watch the part where you're on promoting
your thing
no they're just going to get to that
underwater thing yeah that one little I
know and it doesn't matter what you're
promoting I always tried to say just
save the film as I come out so I can do
I want to work I have six minutes of new
material for them because I want the
audience to go oh he was good he didn't
just talk about his film and play table
tennis
so I come I try and come up with new
material every time I doing these things
and it's just wasted right I'm just the
opposite I'm desperate to get on and be
I like I played with table tennis I
don't give a [ __ ] or anything until
outlets for Starbucks doesn't cone and
do one just Conan all the time I know
that he's in Vallon he does stand-up oh
we still do it at the balance so I hear
that's a night show I know I hear the
name is oh yeah oh yeah yeah that was a
good one that one we actually got some
views oh yeah how did nobody sees it
that I also gone but also it what inside
you out because like a new comic doing
little clubs it's it's massive that you
know that even that even if a million
people see it and like it that sells out
every one of you shows everywhere in the
country doesn't it our new young girl
I'm a club comic and I've done Conan
five times no no real bump really as a
bar but when did it when is it did it
have to be I suppose sometimes it's like
not just showing it but having someone
talk about it is when it starts taking
off like yes so it's going to be
word-of-mouth and go viral I guess well
yeah they have to find a clip it goes
everywhere on Facebook via myspace yeah
well vice but Facebook is phenomenal
Facebook yes it's scary 1.8 billion
people on Facebook and the engagements
more than Twitter because people go on
it by themselves and as families so they
they actually read Facebook they don't
just scroll through Twitter trying to
find funny they actually read read
Facebook and watch the things because
it's you know they also
it's usually on a desktop or something
I've opposed to your phone so the
engagements really it's really important
Facebook I think they they can they can
challenge like Amazon and Netflix next
if they wanted to they could do a little
programming I hopefully I hopefully they
will since some Amazon Netflix of
rejected me let's help the Facebook does
something yeah that's like sure no yeah
yeah um size of live I do it sometimes
yeah and a lot of people do become
engaged with it and watch it oh yeah and
they try me I know that I think it said
it gets a notification and so people are
sometimes filmic are and it gets 200,000
views your your Jane
tweet and [ __ ] instagrams are so funny
yet yeah James little afraid he'll want
a you ever get whatever get like not
looking good standing a park looking a
tree by yourself you fresh